[Music]  hello friends i am beyond excited to  announce that we are teaming up with  johnson and johnson this holiday season  to celebrate the amazing impact of  nurses in healthcare they have a 125  year history of supporting nurses and we  all know how thankful we are for  everything that nurses do from  innovating on the front lines of the  pandemic to community outreach to those  in need they are unstoppable and we want  to celebrate our nurses who make health  systems work  when we care for those who care for us  everybody wins and if you are a nurse or  know a nurse who would like to be a part  of this special show  please head to the drewberrymart  show.com  nurses because we want to hear from you  [Music]